today is tax day the deadlines for
Americans to file their return but if
you're expecting a refund you may want
to check your bank account first the IRS
says identity thieves are targeting tax
preparation firms hacking their online
accounts to then file phony refund
requests since 2013 they have stolen 63
million dollars Anna Werner is
investigating the scam and shows us how
to avoid becoming its next victim good
morning we followed the scammers trail
to Duncan Oklahoma population 30,000
where we found this scam has turned many
people's lives upside down police
officer David woods supports a family of
five on his City salary so when he went
to check his bank balance one day he was
surprised to find at about nine thousand
fifteen dollars more than I anticipated
a roughly nine thousand dollar tax
refund from the IRS with just one
problem it couldn't be real it didn't
make sense because I did not follow my
taxes I even got my w-2 to follow my
taxes so there's no way you could have
had a refund none no and that's when I
knew there was something way out of
place he was right it's a new tax scam
here's how it works the criminals get
their hands on returns from previous
years then use that information to file
new fraudulent returns on unsuspecting
victims after the refund goes into the
victims bank account the crooks posing
as debt collectors for the IRS follow up
with a phone call claiming the refund
was an error then direct them to a
fraudulent website to return the money
sure enough scammers called officer
woods a week later I told her I said you
listen to me you piece of crap suffice
to say he told them all crooks and
cheats I don't like it he returned the
money to the government but now the IRS
says his real refund of $3,000 will be
delayed possibly for months and he's not
the only victim here in Duncan I had a
gut feeling that something was wrong
tax preparer Annette Kraft says at least
230 of her clients have been affected by
the scam they are losing
out because they were expecting this
money like 91 year-old Rae Pro throw who
found out about the scam from the IRS
while we were there
his refund will be coming late as will
tire shop manager Jerry Duvall's $5,800
returned already more than two months
late we planned on you know taking care
of expenses getting caught up on bills
and I mean well you know we counted on
it he missed a $200 car payment and on
the very day we spoke with him my car
got repoed they repossessed your car I'm
sorry
that's hard it's almost like they're
robbed and they are in desperate need a
lot of people are so it's not just one
tax preparer here in Duncan Oklahoma
we've learned that there may be as many
as a hundred tax preparers across the
country affected by this scam and those
are just the ones that they know of so
that could be tens of thousands of
taxpayers don4t heads the IRS is
Criminal Investigation Division we've
seen an enormous uptick in the activity
hackers attempting to get information
from tax professionals his agent showed
us where hackers then sell that
information on the dark web one seller
offered this as an example
it's a Midwestern couples full 2016 tax
return these people this couple have no
idea that their returns are sitting out
there on the dark web for sale yeah
probably not the seller offered 200 tax
returns for the equivalent of $8,000 100
percent satisfaction guaranteed they
said the IRS is investigating but says
the crooks are likely organized crime
rings overseas and out of reach but back
in Duncan Kraft says the damage they've
done to her business is real my clients
are more like a family I want them to
know that they can trust me that I can
trust them
Hertz well so far the IRS can't say
exactly how the hackers are operating
Kraft says her own computer experts tell
her
they don't believe her systems were
hacked but that still leaves the
question of how exactly those hacks are
being masterminded but bianna there is
some good news to report this morning
for the tire shop employee Jere Duvall
after we first highlighted his situation
some people came forward to help him out
he now has his car back such good news
for him right ending to that story that
shows you how these crooks are messing
with people's lives and I like officer
woods he's no joke to you we really
think he said you piece of crap well I
don't know morning television I don't
know but nominee for the next IRS
Commissioner there you go Anna did the
story too very important